[Music]
on this Tuesday night from London Her
Majesty back at Buckingham Palace
it's lining the streets to bid her
farewell I just want to come here and
pay my respects myself in my own way
Canada's national day of mourning when
it will happen and which provinces will
recognize it the Toronto Police Service
loses one of its own why he may have
been targeted by a gunman and deflating
inflation frustration these are things
that will make a difference ottawa's
promise to make life more affordable
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight from London
on a dark and rainy night in London
another step on her final Journey the
Queen's coffin arriving at Buckingham
Palace to spend one last night there
a huge crowd gathered to witness it
earlier King Charles and the queen
concert visited Northern Ireland
continuing their tour of the four
nations of the United Kingdom in the
crowd of well-wishers the king spotting
something familiar a corgi his mother's
favorite breed of dog
later though a sign of how grueling the
last few days have been
the king frustrated by a leaky fountain
pen when signing a visitor's book at
Hillsborough Castle
the Queen's only daughter Princess Anne
has traveled with the coffin since it
left Balmoral Castle and today she put
out a statement saying I was fortunate
to share the last 24 hours of my dearest
mother's life it has been an honor and a
privilege to accompany her on her final
Journeys
good evening and thanks for joining us
Her Majesty's coffin is now here in
London one step closer to her funeral on
Monday crystal gemancing is with me
crystal those huge crowds outside
Buckingham Palace it was really quite
moving what's the significance of the
coffin being there tonight well everyone
recognizes Buckingham Palace and of
course it is the official residence of
The Sovereign here in London but more
than that it is where the queen and some
members of her family will spend a final
night under the same roof
five days after the notice of her death
was attached the imposing iron gates
welcomed the queen home
one last time
the oak coffin will rest overnight in
the bow room a bright space overlooking
the garden where the queen entertained
dignitaries
I was walking yesterday so I did watch
it on the news so I told myself I said
today I will be here I was just crying
and then I said to myself I said no
today I'm not going to miss today I need
to be here
this small garden area near the Palace
of holyrood house a refuge for many
needing to express their grief and pay
respects personal little notes and Gifts
tucked into the thick blanket of
bouquets they've also lost
um
someone who was greatly respected and
admired and so everyone is um I think on
the whole wishing them well the Princess
Royal has been at the Queen's side since
her last day continuing her role as
companion they left Scotland a place her
mother loved for the last time
[Music]
the national anthem played as the Royal
Air Force C-17 taxied slowly down the
runway lifting off into a Setting Sun
[Music]
in London an English welcome a steady
rain adding to the solemn moment the
weather not a factor for people lining
the root from the Royal Air Force
Station Northolt to Central London
Vehicles stopped on the motorway as the
state hers with interior lights on
drawing attention to the flag-draped
coffin made its way to the Palace
the queen often said she has to be seen
to be believed and it's believed that
hundreds of thousands will visit her
coffin as it lies in state at
Westminster hall for four days and if
that experience is anything like it was
for people in Edinburgh it will be
deeply profound and emotional all right
crystal the mansion in London thank you
the king and queen consort are inside
Buckingham Palace tonight earlier today
they were in Northern Ireland they're
visiting each of the nations in the
United Kingdom to receive condolences
before the Queen's funeral between the
1960s and the 1990s more than 3 500
people were killed during the so-called
troubles as Redmond Shannon reports the
new Monarch's visit was a reminder how
far Northern Ireland has come
arriving in Belfast the new King Charles
III greeted by children from an
integrated school but despite Northern
Ireland's two decades of relative peace
almost all kids still go to schools
segregate gated by religion for
Catholics who mostly identify as Irish
or for Protestants who often identify as
British
outside Hillsborough castle some could
barely contain their joy
for many Northern Irish unionists love
of the crown is an important part of
their identity one that some see as
threatened by a shifting political
landscape
that Illustrated inside the castle the
king meeting Michelle O'Neill Northern
Ireland's first Minister designate an
Irish Republican who rejects the
monarchy and seeks reunification with
Ireland a meeting once Unthinkable Irish
Republicans killed the king's beloved
great uncle Lord mountbatten
while Charles himself spent decades as
Colonel in Chief of the parachute
regiment
blamed for one of the deadliest days of
Northern Ireland's troubles Bloody
Sunday
today even Republican leaders say the
late Queen Elizabeth helped to heal
those wounds
the day of the Queen's funeral has been
declared a Federal holiday by the
Canadian government that means federal
workers will have the day off but as
Eric Sorensen reports it doesn't mean
next Monday will be a holiday for every
Canadian
a national holiday to mourn the passing
of Canada's Queen is like the monarchy
itself a complicated subject in this
country well why not Therese Alfieri
believes a holiday is appropriate she's
always been part of our Lives regardless
and I think that in itself is something
to honor
not so says Aida Morris I don't think we
need the holiday for the queen why well
I'm not a monarchist but a national
holiday it should be and will be says
the Prime Minister there are still a few
details to be worked out but declaring
an opportunity for Canadians to mourn on
Monday is going to be important the
Prime Minister says he'll work with the
provinces and territories but Quebec's
Premier suggested today his Province
won't take the day off and he'll keep
campaigning for re-election
yeah something else to consider a
national holiday can also have an impact
on the economy a day off for many people
could be a boost for tourism but it can
also set back overall economic activity
at retro rides in Ottawa a day when more
Canadians can relax with activities like
bike riding can be good for business
we'll be open because you know we're a
bike shop but Jason commandot says these
are tough Economic Times for which a
holiday does not help we have rent and
all the operating costs for business
don't go away one business group is
urging provinces not to follow the
federal lead to avoid another blow to
economic productivity we're still
fighting inflationary pressures the
added cost to a business even if it's
just today is significant and something
we'd like to avoid if we're able well
they actually reflect on the Queens
passing Monday will be a poignant day
and for many Canadians a holiday on
short notice as the Prime Minister said
means there are details to be worked out
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
the liberal government announced plans
it says will help deal with Rising
prices more than 4.5 billion dollars
have been earmarked to help Canadians
cope with the soaring cost of living
including the first steps in that long
talked about Federal Dental Care Program
Abigail Beeman explains what's promised
[Laughter]
speaking from a New Brunswick peer the
Prime Minister outlines steps liberals
say will help Canadians struggling with
record inflation these are things that
will make a difference in people's lives
right now but they are also sufficiently
targeted that we are confident that they
will not contribute to increased
inflation the Liberals are promising to
double the GST credit for six months
offer direct payments for dental care
for low-income uninsured children under
12 this year and a one-time 500 Top-Up
to the Canada housing benefit for
renters Pierre poliev meanwhile
announced his new leadership team and
launched his first official attack on a
liberal announcement as official
opposition leader the problem with
spending more money
as a solution to inflation is that it
simply pours more gasoline on the
inflationary fire the liberal plan will
cost more than 4.5 billion dollars at
least 3.1 billion is on top of money
promised in budget 2022. none of these
measures will do anything for inflation
or try to Target prices in any way
they're an offset for the increase in
prices the NDP are taking all the credit
pushing the Liberals for tangible action
on their governance deal this
parliamentary session we're proud that
we're able to use our power to get
something meaningful for Canadians to
force this government to do something
meaningful for Canadians Tuesday's
dental care plan is just the first stage
and the Canadian Dental Association
believes it really will make a
difference seeing too many kids for
their first appointment too late and
already struggling if we're able to see
children earlier we can prevent a lot of
dental disease from happening there are
some tremendous opportunities here to
make a difference the Prime Minister
says the steps outlined Tuesday will be
the first legislation to be tabled when
the House of Commons resumes next week
MPS have wrapped up their caucus Retreat
here heading back to Ottawa for a
special session in Parliament Thursday
to commemorate the death of the queen
Abigail Beeman Global News Saint Andrews
New Brunswick
the Toronto Police Service in shock and
grieving coming up the slain officer
being remembered as a gentle giant plus
Ukraine's new goal in Russia's War
good
two fathers won a police officer the
other the owner of a mechanic shop are
being remembered today Constable Andrew
Hong served 22 years on the force he was
shot and killed while on his lunch break
and community members say Shakila Ashraf
was joyful always helping to fix cars
even if clients couldn't afford it their
deaths and the injuries of three others
are now under investigation Mike jerlay
reports
the lights from dozens of police
vehicles cut through the Toronto night
lighting the way for a procession of
honor to escort Constable under Hong's
body to the coroner's office Toronto
police lining the street their faces a
mix of shock and confusion this morning
as the police chief met with Hong's
colleagues it was clear the new day
brought few answers we've got a whole
host of Civilian members in here that
have known some of them have worked with
them for 20 years they're they're quite
distraught over the whole situation it
was 2 15 P.M Monday when Constable Hong
and another person were shot in what
police are calling an ambush at 3 25 PM
another man is killed and two others
wounded in nearby Milton appeal police
and Halton police send out near
identical tweets about the suspect
leading to an emergency alert being
issued at 4 25 PM just over an hour
later Hamilton Police confront Sean
Petrie who died in a shootout
the second victim has been identified as
Shaquille Ashraf a father of three and
the owner of an auto repair shop where
Petrie reportedly used to work there
doesn't appear to be any connection
between Petrie and Hong a 22-year
veteran of the force and father of two
who's been described as a gentle giant
Constable hung was blatantly shot in the
back for wearing a uniform
you know I'm just getting chills talking
to you guys it's uh it's very very tough
an investigation has been launched but
it could be months or longer before
police released their findings you want
it you want it to be done properly you
and this so we do not want to rush and
we do not want to rush with information
out into the public what happened he
says will come in time for now there is
only grief over the loss of two men one
in the line of duty microwave Global
News Toronto
Ukrainian officials now say their aim is
to recapture all russian-controlled
territory within that country to extend
what they're already calling a highly
successful counter-offensive
this is
President Vladimir zielinski says
Ukrainian forces have now liberated more
than 6 000 square kilometers since the
beginning of September an area slightly
larger than Prince Edward Island Russia
has admitted to losing key cities in the
Northeast but the Kremlin calls it a
regrouping and not a retreat
several dozen soldiers have been killed
in a string of skirmishes along the
border between Armenia and Azerbaijan
both countries are accusing the other of
triggering the latest round of
hostilities in a decades-old dispute
over one area of Azerbaijan that is
largely populated by ethnic Armenians a
dispute led to a full-scale war in the
1980s and 90s and a six-week war in 2020
both the U.S and Russia are calling for
a ceasefire and for both Nations to
return to the negotiating table
how the Queen's death could change the
reach of the royal brand
Queen Elizabeth's passing is a major
moment in history and it's likely to
have an impact on the UK economy you can
already see the immediate effects the
bank holiday on Monday thousands of
people flooding into London and of
course all those Royal souvenirs a quick
Google search reveals all sorts of
unofficial King Charles merchandise
already on sale but at stake 2 is the
future of the Royal Family's brand which
is Anne gaviola explains might never
financially recover from the Queen's
death
the Queen's death marks not only the
loss of the UK and Canada's
constitutional head but the figurehead
and brand ambassador of the monarchy
itself I mean there really is no one
like the queen right the Royal Family's
brand value was ranked fourth globally
in 2017 behind only Google Apple and
Amazon
the royal family Enterprise known as The
Firm is a pillar of UK tourism Goodwill
and Trade Services and merchandise
Nostalgia spending is likely to drive a
short-term bump in revenue for a beloved
Queen I must confess I I shed a few
tears because she was such a remarkable
woman the royal family Enterprise costs
British taxpayers 700 million annually
and generates 3.7 billion in Revenue
there will be one-time costs for the
Queen's funeral the coronation of King
Charles III and a national holiday costs
analysts say could tip Britain into a
small technical recession though the
King has committed to running a
financially slimmed down Enterprise but
many question how her son and family
will fare as brand custodians the
popularity of the monarchy abroad has
certainly dwindled in certain years and
people feel it's it is out of touch or
it's dated a new survey from Leisure
finds Canadians split on whether Charles
will be a good King but the vast
majority are pretty indifferent to
Canada's new head of state the
significance of the queen passing away
may feel almost a you know alien or
divorced experience and I think that
there is going to be a certain degree of
discourse that will need to happen in
Canada around the idea of of the place
of the royal family the debate now is
what role the new monarchy and its
storied and controversial Legacy will
play in modern Canada and gaviola Global
News Toronto
next the history of the ancient building
where the queen Will lion state
one million people or more are expected
to come here to the heart of London to
see the queen lying in state and the
government is already warning people the
queue will be very long possibly all
night and there will be little
opportunity to sit down yet even more
than 30 hours before anyone can get into
the line of State people are already
lining up I went to talk to some of them
this is a moment in history these people
don't want to miss Glenn Norris says
even if you're not a monarchist it feels
like the world has lost a grandmother it
might be raining at the moment but she
reigned for 70 years so a little bit of
rain is not going to hurt me for 24
hours they're lining up across the river
from Westminster Hall prepared in both
body and spirit you're obviously
prepared to do what it takes to see her
lying inside yes definitely absolutely
prepared yeah prepared to stay all night
got warm clothes food drinks
to honor a great lady why did you feel
you had to be here because she just
meant so much to me
she's been part of my life all my life
multiply that feeling by tens of
thousands and that's what's expected
along the route to the lying in State
starting Wednesday afternoon for 24
hours a day until early Monday morning
the Queen's coffin will lie here inside
the only part of the ancient Palace of
Westminster which survives in almost its
original form built in 1097 Westminster
Hall has played a central role in
British history astonishing not just for
its size and magnificent Timber roof but
for what's gone on here Henry VII was
crowned Charles the first and Guy Fox
were tried and condemned Nelson Mandela
addressed Parliament here and 70 years
ago the Queen's father King George VI
lay in stayed here hundreds of thousands
of people lined the route to pay their
respects his daughter then a young Queen
Elizabeth was among them and when the
king died the King was stretched
from there all the way along the road
behind me and over 400 000 people filed
past which was considered a lot in those
days it'll be considerably more this
time because a lot more people knew of
the queen for now the Queen's coffin
will spend one last night in her old
home before what's expected to be an
unparalleled Act of public Mourning
and the funeral for the queen will take
place next Monday at Westminster Abbey
right behind me we will have live
coverage as the royal family and people
from around the world say goodbye to the
longest reigning monarch in history
that is global national for this Tuesday
from London I'm Donna Friesen we leave
you tonight with more images from the
funeral Cortez the Queen's coffin
carried by her color Squadron then
driven through London watched by
thousands of people lining the route
before resting for a final night inside
Buckingham Palace
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]